الرئيس المنتخب جو بايدن يشيد
بالعاملين في المجال الطبي الليلة على
الخطوط الأمامية لمكافحة فيروس كورونا
، لا يكفي أن نثني عليك ، علينا
حمايتك ،
علينا أن ندفع لك أنه يسلط الضوء
على
بطولتهم وينادي إعاقة الرئيس ترامب
لأن إدارته
لا تزال  يرفض التعاون مع
الفريق الانتقالي لبايدن
خاصة في محاربة كوفيد ، لم نتمكن من
الوصول إلى أنواع الأشياء التي نحتاج إلى
معرفتها
حول عمق المخزونات التي
نعلم أنه لا يوجد الكثير منها على
الإطلاق وهناك الكثير من الأشياء
فقط ليس لدينا ما هو متاح لنا ،
ما لم يتم توفيره قريبًا ، فسوف
نتخلف لأسابيع أو أشهر ، ومع ذلك تم توجيه الموظفين
داخل وزارة الصحة والخدمات البشرية
بعدم
التواصل مع أي من مستشاري
بايدن تعلمته سي إن إن
و  طُلب منك الإبلاغ عن أي تواصل مع كبار
مسؤولي الوكالة ،
لقد أوضحنا تمامًا أنه عندما تتخذ وكالة الأمن القومي
قرارًا ،
فسوف نضمن أستاذًا تعاونيًا كاملاً
التحولات والتخطيط المهني حيث أبلغت الولايات المتحدة
عن أكثر الأيام دموية
للوباء في ستة أشهر
، توسلت ممرضة من مينيسوتا إلى بايدن للحصول على مزيد من
المساعدة ،
لقد اعتنيت بزملاء العمل
أثناء كفاحهم من أجل الحفاظ على حياتهم باستخدام
جهاز التنفس
الصناعي ومعرفة أنهم مرضوا بسبب
من المستشفى
أو حكومتهم لم
تحمهم ، أظهر بايدن تعاطفه ،
قال هذا أنا آسف ، أنا عاطفي للغاية
،
لقد جعلني أشعر بالعاطفة الليلة.
متشككًا في أي
خطط موثوقة موجودة
داخل إدارة ترامب ،
سنكون مستعدين في اليوم الأول
الذي انتظرنا فيه 10 أشهر حتى يتم
مشاركة خطة مع الجمهور الأمريكي
وخبراء الرعاية الصحية في
برنامج اللقاح ،
كما يضع فريق بايدن الانتقالي  أولوية عالية
لبناء الحكومة
وخاصة مسؤولي وزارة الصحة والخدمات الإنسانية
يقولون لشبكة CNN
أن اثنين من المحافظين الديمقراطيين هما الآن
أكبر المتنافسين على منصب
جينا.  imondo من جزيرة
رود وميشيل ليوان جريشام من المكسيك الجديدة ،
هم مع الدكتور فيفيك مورثي ، الجراح العام السابق ،
من بين المتنافسين الرئيسيين على
المنصب ، كل هذا يقول إن مستشاري بايدن
ينتقدون محاولة ترامب لتقويض
الديمقراطية بإقالة كريس كريبس الذي كان مسؤولاً
عن  الأمن السيبراني للانتخابات الأمريكية
لقول الحقيقة بشأن الانتخابات
إنه أمر خطير
أن سلوك ترامب الانتقالي بأكمله في
الوقت الحالي
يجب أن يخيف الجمهور الأمريكي